(energetic acoustic music)
- Across the whole foods system,
20% of fruits and
vegetables that are grown
never make it to a human mouth.
Food waste is a complex
problem, some of it is
because of the really
tight aesthetic standards
of the grocery stores,
need to be perfectly round,
the same size, the same color.
My name is Ben Chesler, and
I'm one of the co-founders
of Imperfect Foods.
(groovy acoustic music)
Imperfect Foods is a
grocery delivery service
that takes produce and groceries
that would normally go to
waste and delivers them
to your door for 30% less
than the grocery store.
We started this because
we noticed there was
an environmental need,
and there was food going to waste.
If food waste were a
country, it would actually be
the third largest emitter
of green house gases,
and then there's all of the
resources, all the water,
all the labor, that goes to waste.
We know the more people we reach,
the bigger impact we're able
to have on the environment.
We wanted to be close to the farmers
and close to the source,
and over half of the
produce consumed in the US
is grown in California,
and San Francisco it was.
We came out here with basically
a forklift, a warehouse,
and the shirts on our backs.
The way we work with farms,
we're here to help them reduce waste,
so every week, farms
basically send us a list
of the fruits and vegetables
that they can't sell,
and we're putting
together a complete menu.
When you talk to the farmers
you really understand
these fruits and vegetables
are kind of their children
and they put so much care
and love into growing them,
and they have so much
pride in their craft.
(rhythmic acoustic guitar music)
- I love farming because
I like the challenge,
I like always going up
against Mother Nature.
Lakeside Organic Gardens,
we farm over 3,000 acres,
we grow over 52 different
types of vegetables,
cilantro, parsley, broccoli,
cauliflower, parsnips,
rutabegas, turnips, lettuces all types,
romaine, green leaf, red
leaf, iceberg, chard.
We consider ourselves a one stop shop
for organic vegetables.
We're in a red cabbage field
where it's just been harvested.
Here on my left, I have
a Lake Side regular box,
and to my right I have the Imperfect box.
All of them are uniform standard, pretty.
This is just exactly the
same, same field, same deal,
just a little bit smaller.
Ideally, for any farmer in this world,
the perfect scenario
is harvest every piece
of produce that's out in the field.
Delicious.
Before we teamed up with Imperfect Foods,
you'd have quite a bit of
product left out in the fields.
Now we have an outlet for those vegetables
that aren't as pretty, but
they taste just the same
as anything else.
Like they say it, "Don't
judge a book by its cover,"
same with vegetables, you know?
If they're a little bit off,
don't knock it till you try it.
(somber banjo music)
- We're here in the
Imperfect Foods warehouse
in San Francisco, and so this
is where all the produce,
the groceries, the meat,
the dairy, everything,
comes in from the farms,
so let's go take a look
at some of the product.
Why would these mandarins go to Imperfect,
not a grocery store, and you
can see some of this, like,
external scarring,
roughness of the outside
or discoloration, little bit of peeling.
The grocery stores really don't want them,
and they would normally
go to waste on the farm.
About a year ago we
expanded beyond produce,
because we noticed that
there was food going to waste
across the whole food system.
It's really well aligned
that every box of produce
and groceries we sell helps
us fight climate change
and do some good for the environment.
One of the main things
that drives us to be better
and keep pushing is knowing
that our work is helping
to leave the planet in a better place
than we found it for our children.
Now we're headed to Food Shift,
which is one of our community
partners in the Bay Area.
So sometimes when we have
product that we can't sell,
we want it to still find a home
so we donate to organizations
like Food Shift.
- We are a combination of
food recovery organization
and a social enterprise kitchen.
We educate folks who would otherwise
face high barrier to entry for employment,
and we hire them for our own enterprise,
catering and distribution
of produced meals.
I want everybody to be mindful
and be kind to each other,
and food is a great way to do that,
'cause when we break our
proverbial bread together,
I think we're closer, we
think about our sameness,
we solve things together, we
put aside our differences,
or we even embrace our differences.
What a privilege that we get to eat,
and what a privilege that we get to cook.
- It's amazing that food
is really so central
to people's identity,
and it can really serve
as a force to bring people together.
It's also one of the biggest issues
affecting climate change,
and in health, and nutrition, obesity.
So it is really crazy how this small seed
turns into a piece of fruit or vegetable
and then basically can have
so many positive effects
on the world.
(happy synth music)
(whooshing)
(creaking)